sokrates meine damen und herren wurde
einst angeklagt weil er die jugend mit
seinen ideen verführt habe mein heutiger
gast hat sich den antiken philosophen
aus athen offenbar zum vorbild genommen
denn mit seinem neuesten buch versucht
die jugend zu verderben will er den
jungen menschen den kopf verdrehen
im radio ist einer der bekanntesten
philosophen in frankreich um das
überzeugter kommunist auch einer der
streitbarsten sein weckruf an uns alle
raus aus der komfortzone
ich fürchte es wird also nicht kuschelig
heute morgen packen wir es an guten
morgen
er war du sie wollen die jugend
verderben denken sie die jugend ist
heute zu angepasst die heutige jugend
ist in einer schwierigen situation finde
ich die philosophen haben sich immer
bevorzugt an die jugend gewendet ich
folge also nur einer tradition
das ist nichts wirklich neues ich denke
ganz einfach man muss sich an die jugend
wenden und zu ihr sprechen weil sie
desorientiert
es ist interessant dass sie sagen dass
die philosophen sich traditionellerweise
an die jugend gewendet haben weil es
gibt auch viele philosophen die sitz in
ihrem elfenbeinturm und haben mit der
jugend nicht so viel zu tun du viel und
ich glaube jede philosoph wünscht sich
zumindest dass die jugend versteht auch
wenn er ein weiser alter mann ist und
somit weit entfernt von den
unsicherheiten der jugendlichen denke
ich dass hier immer von der jugend
angezogen haben ganz einfach weil sie
die zukunft darstellt und somit auch die
zukunft die philosophie die ideen was
aus indien des philosophen wird zeigt
sich durch die jugendwehr sich nur alle
gleichaltrige wendet stirbt mit ihnen
aus und die ideen der zukunft kommen die
heute wirklich noch von der philosophie
ist es nicht so dass heutzutage
nicht im takt vorgibt und die
philosophen rennen nur als kommentatoren
hinten nach das finde ich keineswegs wie
du so philosophen befinden sich seit
jeher in einer etwas paradoxen position
gegenüber dem staatswesen und seinen
grundlagen sie sind immer ein wenig
abseits
sie haben nie die materielle situation
der bürger verändert oder neue dinge
erfunden
manchmal übernehmen sie die rolle des
kommentators aber als kritische stimmen
mit in die zukunft gerichteten
innovativen gedanken und aus dieser
sicht sind ihre beiträge zu neuerungen
womöglich wichtiger als die anderer
schließlich kennt man die erfinder des
feuers und der architektur oder die
erbauer der pyramiden nicht mehr aber
platon könne man bis heute wobei
natürlich die pyramide auch nicht von
einer person erbaut wurde sondern unter
anderem ganz dienstwaffen
ja auf jeden fall zählt der vergleich
zwischen dem philosophen und den anderen
immer darauf ab festzustellen dass der
philosoph eigentlich und im grunde
stimmt es auch dass wir nicht von nutzen
sind
denn jede gesellschaft definiert selbst
was hier nützlich ist und was sie selber
leistet der philosoph befindet sich
immer ein bisschen in schieflage in
einer kritischen position
man kann also durchaus sagen er sei
eigentlich uns außerdem gibt es nicht
überall auf der welt philosophen in
gewissen ländern hat sich die
philosophie nicht wirklich etabliert
dort gibt es eine religion eine
vorherrschende ideologie aber keine
tradition der kritischen philosophie
diese hat in griechenland ihren ursprung
und ihre eigene geschichte
welche länder denken sie an die samen es
gibt länder in denen es nicht wirklich
eine philosophische tradition gibt es
gibt länder mit weisheitslehren die
nichts mit der rationalen kritischen
philosophie gemein haben die uns
griechenland gelehrt hat in
langenreichen und wunderbaren geschichte
chinas zum beispiel findet man keine
philosophie man findet moralische
meditations- und weisheitslehren und
auch aberglauben aber nicht die idee
dass man das was ist in einem möglichst
rationalen denkmodell begreifen kann
das ist etwas einzigartiges das
inzwischen auf der ganzen welt
verbreitet aber eine eigene geschichte
hat jetzt wenn ihr zu diesem buch
zurückgehen oder zum weckruf in diesem
buch und ich glaube es ist ein weckruf
der ehre ganze philosophie jagen nicht
begleitet dann kann man den
zusammenfassen vielleicht mit dem slogan
raus aus der komfortzone
warum eigentlich wenn es doch da so
gemütlich ist
ich sage nicht nur heraus aus der
komfortzone ich sage auch heraus aus dem
nihilismus zwilling des komforts
denn die jugend neigt immer dazu mit der
bestehenden gesellschaft zu brechen oder
sie zu erneuern
und ich habe den eindruck die heutige
jugend ist zunehmend gespalten die einen
jugendlichen und richten sich im komfort
die ihnen geboten wird ein hören sich
einen guten platz in der gesellschaft
gründen ein startup und verdienen viel
geld damit und so weiter andere
jugendliche kritisieren diesen komfort
oder weisen ihn zurück meist aus
objektiven gründen
sei es weil sie vernachlässigt oder
missachtet wurden oder auch weil sie die
kritische philosophie ernst nehmen
die dollen buch schreibe ich dass weder
das sich einlässt und im wohlstand noch
dessen nihilistische kritik nach der no
future devise ich verbrenne mein leben
der rest ist mir egal
haltungen sind mit der sich die jugend
ihre zukunft aufbauen kann
es ist also eine doppelte kritik ich
kritisiere nicht nur den bequemen
westlichen wohlstand sondern auch eine
form der kritik die sich als radikal
versteht aber eher zerstörerisch ist als
etwas aufzubauen ist die trägerschaft um
unten raus zu kommen braucht sie ja so
etwas wie das ereignis und das ereignis
ist der zentrale begriff ihrer
philosophie ihre ganze philosophie dreht
sich immer wieder um dieses ereignis und
das ereignis ist ein moment der totale
überraschung in dem etwas ganz neues
entsteht eine neue sichtweise anbricht
und ich möchte gerne mit ihnen
herausfinden worum es dabei genau geht
weil das klingt erst einmal ziemlich
abstrakt jetzt stehen wir ja kurz vor
weihnachten ist die geburt von jesus ein
ereignis etwas habe ich immer betonen im
moment wo das ereignis stattfindet ist
dessen ausgang unklar
zuerst einmal geschieht ein ereignis
es ist nicht es gibt einen gegensatz
zwischen geschehen und sei ein ereignis
geschieht und verschwindet wieder auch
sehr bedeutende und bekannte ereignisse
wie der mai 68 der mich politisch
geformt hat sind von begrenzter dauer
sie kommen und gehen in gewisser
hinsicht wird ein ereignis nach seinen
folgen beurteilt ob sich die menschen
davon haben inspirieren lassen oder ob
sie ihr leben neu ausgerichtet haben
solche dinge machen im nachhinein aus
etwas geschehen
sie haben die geburt christi erwähnt da
kann man nun wirklich nicht behaupten
sie hätten keinen erfolg und keine
zukunft gehabt
man machte daraus viel mehr über die
jahrtausende ein so großes konstrukt das
man nicht mehr sicher weiß ob das
ereignis stattgefunden hat oder nicht
aber das ist nicht so schlimm
es genügt die überzeugung dass etwas
wichtiges passiert ist dass das leben
umkrempelt oder hilft sich neu zu
orientieren
dieses fundamentale dass sich dazu trägt
dem ereignis muss das notwendig positiv
sein oder ist zum beispiel der zweite
weltkrieg ist das auch ein ereignis
da muss man etwas unterscheiden
ein ereignis das ist sehr wichtig nenne
ich etwas das eine neue möglichkeit
schafft das ereignis schafft keine neue
realität vielleicht schaffen die folgen
des ereignisses eine neue realität
das nenne ich in meinem job eine neue
wahrheit großteil realität
was das ereignis in seinem bereich
eröffnet ist eine neue möglichkeit eine
neue möglichkeit die vorher unmöglich
schien
sonst wäre es keine neue möglichkeit das
ereignis verändert also die beziehung
zwischen dem möglichen und dem
unmöglichen ganz einfach weil es etwas
möglich machen was bis anhin unmöglich
über diese möglichkeit muss man sprechen
und etwas daraus machen
sie realisieren geschieht das nicht geht
das ereignis vergessen hat und hat sich
eigentlich gar nichts ereignet
stattgefunden hat es nur wenn dieser
möglichkeit ergriffen und entwickelt
wird und daraus etwas entsteht
es sind also nicht die wichtigen oder
schrecklichen dinge die ich ereignissen
hat etwa der zweite weltkrieg neue
möglichkeiten eröffnet davon weiß ich
nichts
das müsste man genauer analysieren er
war vor allem negativ man hat damit
verhindert dass die nazis europa erobert
haben aber ok dem handeln der menschen
eine neue möglichkeit einen neuen
horizont eröffnet hat ist eine andere
frage operativen zu drücken sie kommen
gerade zurück aus den usa und ich frage
mich natürlich auch ist denn die wahl
von kramp ein solches ereignis und in
dieser frage klingt für mich auch mit
die frage kann man das ereignis objektiv
definieren oder ist es so dass für die
einen die haus und trump ein ereignis
ist weil eben neue möglichkeiten
entstehen für die anderen ist es kein
ereignis weil sie den eindruck haben
nein das verschließt möglichkeiten
ich glaube das was allgemein passiert
ist nicht unbedingt ein ereignis
auch wenn es etwas überraschendes ist
das eindruck macht und große
auswirkungen
denn wie ich schon sagte die zukunft ist
entscheidet auch wenn das ereignis eine
neue möglichkeit schafft erst die
stabilisierung die realisierung dieser
möglichkeit konsolidiert gewissermaßen
nehmen wir nun die wahl von kramp da sie
diese erwähnt haben die kann man sicher
als eine wichtige und überraschende
tatsache bezeichnet
natürlich unterscheide ich tatsache und
ereignis bei einer tatsache weiß man
nicht ob es sich um die schaffung einer
neuen möglichkeit im affirmativen
innovativen sinn handelt es kann eine
reaktion sein eine regression
ich denke die wahl vom tram kann man
vorerst nicht als ereignis bezeichnen
nun noch kennen wir die folgen nicht
dass trump macht oder nicht macht liegt
noch ziemlich im dunkeln
mit sicherheit ist sie ein symptom ein
symptom ist keinesfalls ein ereignis an
symptomen sagt vielmehr etwas aus über
die welt wie sie ist
es schafft keine neue möglichkeit ich
denke die wahl von trump ist
vergleichbar mit den hohen wahlchancen
von marine le pen in meinem land oder
mit der situation in lateinamerika
goro die meisten linken regierungen
durch reaktionäre ersetzt worden
das alles ist ein symptom für eine neue
weltweite situation zu schlafen
ein symptom wo 44 posco symptom gilt ein
symptom für die möglichkeit in der
politik eine andere richtung einschlagen
zu können
eine richtung wie zb dem heutigen
kapitalismus etwas anderes entgegen
setzen würde vielleicht diskutieren wir
später darüber was das sein könnte
auf jeden fall eine alternative
gebürstet publikum
doch diese perspektive ist momentan sehr
geschwächt und zwar so sehr mit dass die
unzufriedenheit die unsicherheit und die
verwirrung eher eine rückwärts geneigte
nostalgie auslösen
nationalistische und rassistische
tendenzen führen die gleichberechtigung
von frauen und männern in frage stellen
und so weiter es ist also eher eine
rückkehr zur alten welt auch immer
dunkel sowie mode und das ist genau das
gegenteil vom ereignis denn das ereignis
schafft eine neue in die zukunft
gerichtete möglichkeit wären diese
tendenzen die sich heute manifestieren
regressiv sind der vergangenheit
zugewandt reaktionär im wahrsten sinn
des wortes
und so muss man sie verstehen dunkel von
tomislav sie haben vorhin selber schon
1968 erwähnt herbert jungen sie sagen
das ist für sie eigentlich war das
wirklich ein ereignisse in ihrem leben
sie waren 1968 31 jahre jung an
vorderster front mit dabei und wir
schauen uns einen ausschnitt an aus dem
jahresrückblick von 1968 aus der
tagesschau in der es genau diese
studentenunruhen geht
die unruhen begannen im april an der
philosophischen fakultät nord der
pariser universität die studenten
führten kleinere aktionen durch die mit
verhaftungen beantwortet wurden
explosionsartig folgte die eskalation
die mit straßenschlachten im gatter
endete
die sorbonne wurde geschlossen
die studenten riefen den hochschul
generalstreik ausführten immer
umfangreicher kundgebungen durch zur
zerschlagung dieser demonstrationen
wurde die pariser bereitschaftspolizei
eingesetzt
er bittet verteidigten die studenten
ihre anliegen dass katar wurde zum
schlachtfeld auf dem höhepunkt der
zusammenstöße am sechsten siebten und
zehnten schlugen sich über 10.000
jugendliche mit ebenso vielen polizisten
hunderte von studenten wurden verhaftet
und zum teil misshandelt
hunderte von polizisten zumeist von
steinen getroffen erlitten verletzungen
noch höher war die verletztenzahl unter
den teilweise übel zugerichteten
demonstranten dieser außergewöhnlichen
erhebungen sie sich in jenem moment
ereignet
[Musik]
erst später kam es aber nur vereinzelt
zu gewaltsamen ausschreitungen
eines davon nicht vergessen was den mai
68 charakterisiert ist das völlig
unerwartete aufeinandertreffen zweier
vorerst völlig verschiedene prozesse
einerseits resultierten studenten und
schüler
es war also eine eigentliche
jugendrevolte wie sie damals fast
überall auf der welt zu beobachten dass
die höheren den usa resultierten die
jugendlichen gegen den vietnamkrieg in
china gehen sie während der
kulturrevolution auf die straße
es gab jugendrevolte in mexiko
eigentlich hat man bis heute noch keine
erklärung gefunden warum ende der 1960
er jahre die jugend überall auf der welt
revoltierte oft aus unterschiedlichen
gründen
aber es war ein weltweites phänomen das
auch frankreich erfasste aber nicht nur
frankreich sondern auch deutschland
italien usw
die fertigung doch in frankreich fand
gleichzeitig der größte generalstreik
der arbeiterstadt den das land je erlebt
hatte im mai 68 trafen also zwei vorerst
ganz verschiedene phänomene aufeinander
die gewaltige revolte der jugend und der
beispiellose aufstand der arbeiter
dadurch wurde der mai 68 zu einem
komplizierten gebilde da zwei
verschiedene aufstände aufeinander
trafen war die beziehung zwischen den
beiden der schlüssel dafür wie sich das
ganze entwickeln würde
und es gab diesbezüglich verschiedene
hypothesen die kommunistische partei war
nicht gerade begeistert von der
situation
sie beanspruchte für sich das alleinige
recht die arbeiter zu mobilisieren und
sah es ungern wie die studenten zu den
favoriten marschierten rote fahnen
schwenkten und die polizei angriffen
das störte ihre strategie höher also
wurden durch die situation alle kräfte
aus dem konzept gebracht
ich nahm an all den teil und erlebte es
wie eine bekehrung um ingo berk kleines
weckte ihn hier die überzeugung dass
sich da vielleicht eine neue politische
möglichkeit auf die politik und das
sehen sie auch immer noch positiv sie
sind jemand der sagt 1968 ist eben ein
ereignis das hat ihr leben nicht nur
einfach erschüttert sondern neue
möglichkeiten eröffnet aber muss man
dazu zb steine werfen würden sie das
nach wie vor auch rechtfertigen
das heißt die tragweite des mai 68
wenn man ihn als ereignis verzeichnet
wird man an seinen auswirkungen messen
ich denke diese frage ist auch nach der
langen zeit noch nicht wirklich geklärt
[Musik]
juli die dorna tropez
denn was hieß es dass in unserem land
aber nicht nur bei uns sondern auch in
italien und sogar in china für männer in
einem ganz anderen kontext jugendliche
und arbeiter massenhaft gemeinsam auf
die straße gingen
während die arbeiter materielle
forderungen stellten ging es der jugend
mehr um gesellschaftliche fragen
um mehr freiheit und weniger familiäre
und soziale unterdrückung
doch diese kombination hat keine
lösungen für die zukunft gebracht
deshalb denke ich der mai 68 ist in
gewisser hinsicht immer noch ein rätsel
was man versucht eigentlich wieder zu
finden was sich damals ergeben hat
rückrufe kees de la paz der die zukunft
hängt davon ab
man weiß genau ein großer isolierter
arbeiter streik ist ein wichtiges
ereignis wird aber die gesellschaft
nicht wirklich erinnern gipfelt den
forderungen und verhandlungen und so
weiter was so richtig positiv für sie
war 1968 ist diese verbrüderung oder
verschwisterung zwischen studierenden
und arbeitenden ja ich denke das war die
wichtige frage die aufhebung dieser
trennung denn ich habe von anfang an
gesagt es waren zwei verschiedene dinge
doch die möglichkeit geschaffen wurde
war die aufhebung dieser trend bei 68
hat den politischen traum geweckt dass
man die gesellschaft durch die
zusammenlegung dieser beiden kräfte
verändern könnte
doch es war nicht von dauer es wurden
viele hypothesen für politische
erneuerungen aufgestellt aber wirkliche
veränderungen kristallisierten sich
nicht heraus die politik bis im
september
erst kürzlich erlebten wir in frankreich
eine wiederholung dieses phänomens wenn
auch viel kleiner
unter dem motto niveau aufrecht durch
die nacht wurde in paris die laster la
république besetzt vor allem von
jugendlichen da gute noten gleichzeitig
gab es gewerkschafts aktionen gegen das
neue in seinen grundzügen gegen das volk
gerichtete arbeitsgesetz es hat sich
also etwas ähnliches wiederholt viel
kleiner süßer rip eine miniatur vom mai
68 viele jahre später als läge ein
problem in der luft das noch nicht
gelöst worden ist und er will ein
problem geht doch
daher baten sie wurden früher schon mit
politik konfrontierte die politik
aufgewachsen ihr vater war in der
résistance aktiv
er war später 14 jahre lang
bürgermeister von toulouse sie selber
waren aktiv in den protesten gegen die
algerien kriege und daneben 1968 sind
sie sehr aktiv
mitgegangen in den ganzen protesten 1985
haben sie selber eine organisation
gegründet eine organisation die
maoistisch war haben sie ihren vater
sozusagen links überholt es kann gut
sein
vielleicht war das immer ein wenig mein
ziel ich möchte aber sagen dass mein
vater schon sehr früh einen großen
einfluss auf mich ausübt
als ich noch ein kind war hatte ich ein
erlebnis das ich ihnen erzählen möchte
denn es war entscheidend für mich
es war während des kriegs
mein vater hatte in unserem hausflur
eine große karte der russischen front
aufgehängt
die sohlen grund garten er verfolgte die
operationen an der russischen front mit
großer sorge denn er beteiligte sich an
der résistance gegen die nazis hülle für
ist eines tages sah ich wie er auf der
karte den faden der front verschoben und
ich verstand mit meinen sechs oder
sieben jahren dass die deutschen zurück
wissen
kühle da fragte ich ihn
die deutschen werden also den krieg
verlieren ich war ein wenig erstaunt
denn ich sah ja deutsche auf unseren
straßen
mein vater gab mir eine antwort die sich
als väterlicher rat in mein gedächtnis
eingegraben hat er sagte natürlich mein
sohn man muss es nur wollen diese idee
dass schlussendlich in der politik der
wille zählt
auch wenn die umstände die
entscheidungen die notwendigkeiten
schwer wiegen hat sich mir tief
eingeprägt gut dafür besorgt weil mein
vater angesichts dieses gewaltigen
phänomens des weltkriegs gesagt hatte
wenn man wirklich widerstand leisten und
gewinnen will muss man es zuerst einmal
wollen
das ist mir geblieben
hinzu kommt für nicht dass sich die
frage des wollens natürlich besonders
stellt wenn wichtige brutale dinge
passieren und man sich fragt was wollen
wir in dieser situation machen
was können wir mit unserem wollen
ausrichtung aber mein vater hat mir
gesagt schlussendlich ist das wollen der
schlüssel sind gut alle verliefen
citigroup select
ich finde das interessant dass jetzt
dieses es wollen und die politik
zusammenbringen weil sie gleichzeitig
auch kritisch der politik gegenüber sind
sie waren zwar immer ein politischer
mensch aber parteipolitisch doch
skeptisch sie haben immer wieder
abgesagt die linke politik sollte sich
eigentlich nicht wirklich einbinden
lassen sondern wirkliche politische
bewegung kommt nur in die sache wenn man
an den parteien vorbei politisiert sie
gehen ja zum beispiel auch gar nicht
wählen
hübner ich glaube es sind nicht die
parteien an und für sich
ich habe immer den eindruck dass die
parteien nicht viel erreichen wollen wir
wollen ist schwach
sie müssen verstehen dass ich praktisch
während meines ganzen lebens die linken
parteien erklärt haben sicher müsste man
dieses oder jenes machen aber sie seien
dazu nicht in der lage wegen der
momentanen situation wegen der krise
wegen der konkurrenz der anderen länder
wegen der währungssituation könnten sie
die gemachten versprechungen nicht
einlösen jurist und das habe ich immer
als große schwäche des politischen
willens verstanden wenn man nur die
konsequenzen aus den situationen zieht
mit die politik nichts
man setzt nur gerade verwalter einige um
die dinge kümmern als handele es sich um
eine bank oder ein großes
handelsunternehmen wenn es um die
geschicke eines landes geht ist das
etwas völlig anderes man muss von zeit
zu zeit neue möglichkeiten ins auge
fassen um die situation wirklich
verändern zu können
ich finde in frankreich aber auch in
vielen anderen ländern sind die linken
parteien spezialisten ja geradezu profis
der enttäuschung geworden
sie verfügen über eine spezielle
rhetorik um zu erklären sie hätten zwar
dies und das versprochen aber die
umstände die welt und der kapitalismus
sei nun halt mal so wie sie sind und da
könnten sie nicht viel ausrichten
diktatur und wenn sie die demokratie
doch irgendwie besser finden müssten sie
sich doch auch beteiligen wählen den usa
lebt man kann zwar wählen gehen aber man
hat keine sicherheit dass die politiker
die man wählt auch halten was sie
versprechen
die wahl ist also ein wenig visionär
automatik wäre man sicher dass jene die
sich zur wahl stellen auch den willen
zur durchsetzung ihrer versprechen
hätten sähe die sache anders aus man
müsste sicher sein können dass sie
wirklich halten was sie versprechen
aber das ist offensichtlich nicht der
fall ständig erlebt man das gleiche
schauspiel eine linke die kaum an der
macht eine ähnliche politik betreibt wie
zuvor die rechte diese fehlende
unterscheidbarkeit und das verschwinden
des politischen wollens hat mich vom
wählen ab
ich habe keine lust ständig enttäuscht
zu werden
das war schon zu oft in meinem leben ich
will doch nicht so weitermachen
sie sind ja nicht glücklich mit der welt
wie sie ist also sowohl in diesem buch
in diesem buch wieder den globalen
kapitalismus für ein neues denken ist
eigentlich klar sie wollen die welt
schon verändern wie wollen sie denn die
welt verändern denn nicht mit der
politik nicht gegen sondern entschieden
die für die politik überdies gehe ich in
meiner philosophie von vier kreativen
registern der menschlichen aktivität aus
in meinem jahrgang nenne ich sie
wahrheit' verfahren das die vier
wahrheit' verfahren sind die
wissenschaft die erfindung
wissenschaftlicher theorien in der
physik und mathematik und so weiter dann
die kunst die erfindung neuer formen
oder arten der präsentationen dann die
liebe die transformation der
persönlichen existenz durch eine
begegnung die politik und schließlich
die politik und zwar eine politik die
den menschlichen willen die welt zu
verändern organisiert sucht da bin ich
voll und ganz dafür
was mir missfällt ist die politik der
enttäuschung
das heißt eine politik die den leuten
sagen wir machen was möglich ist aber
nichts was als unmöglich deklariert
wurden
doch wer entscheidet was möglich und was
unmöglich ist das ist das problem in der
politik es geht nicht nur darum das
mögliche zu tun sondern auch das
unmögliche zu warten also das verhältnis
zwischen möglichen und unmöglichen zu
verschieben ihr votum gegen das team up
prinzip der is no alternativ sie sagen
ganz klar natürlich gibt es eine
alternative um zu diesen alternativen
gehört für sie beispielsweise nach wie
vor der kommunismus ist die idee des
kommunismus ja auch nicht wirklich
wahnsinnig neu auch die idee des
kommunismus hat ein stück weit wenn man
historisch prägt ihre probleme und ein
stück weit einfach auch versagt hat
nicht wirklich funktioniert wenn man es
umgesetzt hat denken ja in china ist
eigentlich nicht wirklich mehr
kommunistisch viele länder die
kommunistisch waren sind kranken zahnlos
mit dieser politik untergegangen wie
genau wollen sie denn den kommunismus
jetzt wieder aus der mottenkiste holen
[Musik]
der kommunismus ist nicht nur ein bloßer
begriff global ist er steht für
vorschläge die neunzehnte jahrhundert
zurückgehen
sie sind nicht von heute und effektiv es
gibt den generellen rahmen des
kommunismus an den habe ich gestern
erinnert als ich in zürich zu jungen
leuten sprach 50 der jury ja ich war
gestern in zürich sprach über den
kommunismus zu einer menge junger leute
die ein theater feld
ich erklärte ihnen der kommunismus sei
nicht der name einer politik an sich
sondern der begriff für eine
weltanschauung
so könnte man das nennen das heißt der
name bekräftigt einzig dass man die
gesellschaft anders organisieren kann
als und das privateigentum das
privateigentum war für jahrtausende der
kern der sozialen politischen und
wirtschaftlichen organisation der
menschheit darüber
zuerst war das eigentum in den händen
der herrschenden später in den händen
der bürger habe aber ich möchte an
diesem punkt daran erinnern dass heute
264 personen gleich viel besitzen wie 3
milliarden der erst lud eine solche
ungleichheit gab es bisher nicht in der
menschheit und das missverhältnis ist
größer als in der absoluten monarchie
kommunismus bedeutet vielleicht in
erster linie dass es auch anders geht
dass man vielleicht eine gleichere
gesellschaft errichten kann
die weniger beherrscht wird von einer
sehr kleinen oligarchien von
kapitalbesitzer jury eigentlich kann man
die kommunistische idee in vier
prinzipien zusammenfassung sie prezi
erstens es muss möglich sein das
schicksal der menschheit der besitz
oligarchie zu entreißen biete du dir mal
zweiter
es muss möglich sein die menschliche
arbeit nicht strikt zu unterteilen in
leitung und ausführung in manuelle und
intellektuelle arbeit in männer und
frauen arbeit um ein paar der
widersprüche zu nennen sie tut sehr gut
klotens man kann vielleicht aufhören
sich zu bekriegen und von identität
nationalität rasse religion und kann im
dienste der ganzen menschheit arbeiten
viertens vielleicht ist die existenz
einer autoritären und abgehobenen
staatsmacht keine definitiven sache der
kommunismus beinhaltet altersgemäße wird
und das kann ich sehr gut nachvollziehen
ich glaube die idee des kommunismus hat
ja so als philosophisches konzept
gesehen ganz viele schöne seiten und die
enorme ungleichheit zwischen den
menschen die muss einem sorgen machen
wenn man einigermaßen sage ich mal
empathie fähig unterwegs ist aber
gleichzeitig merke ich immer es gibt
diese eine große idee des kommunismus
wie sich jetzt heraus kristallisiert
haben oder wir können auch axel honneth
nehmen der von der idee des sozialismus
spricht alles wunderschöne konstrukte
aber ich frage mich trotzdem immer wie
sollen wir denn dahin gelangen was
empfehlen sie
wenn ich ihnen sage ich möchte gerne
dass das was sie beschrieben haben
realität wird was soll ich tun
ja was tun das ist die grundlegende
frage bin ich einverstanden
was soll man putin fell sowie wissen sie
in der politik macht man nur etwas von
dem man wirklich überzeugt zuerst muss
man glauben dass man es machen kann
da muss man beginnen der ratschlag
meines vaters darauf kommen wir immer
wieder zurück man muss den willen haben
die möglichkeit zu ergreifen
the dead gewisse die parade wird
vielleicht kommt einem ein ereignis zu
hilfe vorhin haben wir gesagt das
ereignis ist die schaffung einer
möglichkeit die zuvor als unmöglich
vielleicht gibt es ein solches ereignis
wie der mai 68 bezüglich möglicher
verbindungen zwischen studenten und
arbeitern die idee ist dass er zehn
jahre lang geholfen was nicht schlecht
ist
aber auch ohne helfen das ereignis muss
man an der überzeugung fest halten dass
sich in der geschichte der menschheit
eine andere möglichkeit auftun kann die
globalisierte kapitalismus schafft
monströse und gefährliche situationen
die zu schweren konflikten führen und
schließlich einen großen krieg auslösen
kann
bis jetzt war es jedenfalls so wenn die
internationalen politischen probleme zu
verworren wurden endeten sie in einem
krieg die vier man muss also den willen
so etwas neuem bezeichnet zudem muss man
darauf vertrauen dass der wille
erfinderisch ist aber dieser wille ist
heute angeschlagen er ist krank
den leuten wird weisgemacht ist jede nur
eine möglichkeit die man sich beugen
müssen
es gibt einen punkt denn ihr selig
scheint heute werbung redet uns ein wie
fantastisch und der kapitalismus die
fixe ev bietet aber die leute wissen
genau und haben die erfahrung gemacht
dass es gigantische ungleichheiten gibt
viele menschen fallen durch die maschen
während auf der anderen seite reichtümer
angehäuft werden die unverzeihlich sind
wenn ich so sagen
das wissen die leute aber man sagt ihnen
das ist vielleicht nicht gut so aber es
gibt keine alternative es ist natürlich
auch eine tatsache dass immer wieder
herausgestrichen wird das eigentlich in
der letzten zeit doch sehr viele
menschen aus der armut befreit worden
sind das system ist zwar nicht perfekt
aber gerade in südostasien sie millionen
von menschen aus der armut befreit
worden und in den mittelstand
hochgerutscht
also ich glaube das misstrauen im system
ist wahrscheinlich doch nicht so
verbreitet wie sich jetzt darstellen
ich denke doch diese menschen die aus
der armut befreit wurden
den mittelstand erreicht haben aber das
sind etwa 30 prozent der menschheit mir
nicht man muss das weltweit betrachten
man muss die 500 millionen chinesischen
arbeiter mit einbeziehen die absolut
miserabel entlohnt werden und weniger
bekommen als zuvor
hinzu kommt der afrikanische kontinent
wo die ärmsten der armen leben
man geht davon aus dass heute rund drei
milliarden menschen total im abseits
stehen das heißt sie besitzen nichts
ohne arbeit beziehen keinen lohn
sie haben keinen zugang zum markt als
folge ihren sie in der welt herum auf
der suche nach einem platz nach arbeit
man darf also die situation nicht
idealisieren die heutige konzentration
der reichtümer ist einzigartig in der
geschichte
es gibt nicht wirklich eine verteilung
man kann tatsächlich eine bescheidene
zunahme des mittelstandes beobachten
aber vor allem in der westlichen welt
und sie stark die finanzkrise 2008 ist
ein symptom der blockierten situationen
look deshalb braucht es den willen diese
weltweite situation zu ändern
das ist zwingend nötig einwände wie man
sollte etwas tun aber man weiß nicht was
sind schwer akzeptierbar
denn sie entsprechen der vorherrschenden
ideologie die uns weismachen will
es ist nicht ideal aber es lässt sich
nicht ändern ich hingegen finde man muss
sagen dass man es anders machen kann und
dann schauen wir wie 79 jahre alt und
ich bewundere das unglaublich mit
welchem feuer sie sich engagieren und
wie sehr sie auch bewegt sind von der
situation wie sie eben global gesehen
ist sie beschreiben in ihrem buch über
die jugend wie verführerisch es ist
nicht einfach mit der eigenen karriere
auseinander zu setzen sich einfach zu
überlegen wie kann ich noch mehr
verdienen wie kann man facebook profil
noch eleganter sein
wie kann ich eine noch schönere wohnung
finden und noch die perfekte frau finden
und so weiter und sie sagen nein es geht
um ein mehr wollen es geht darum aus
ihrer komfortzone
auszukommen woher nehmen sie diese
energie ist das einfach ihr vater der da
immer noch irgendwie vorschlägt oder was
treibt sie an
es gibt motiv sie was mich motiviert ist
banaler eigentlich wünsche ich den
jungen menschen dass sie ein
interessantes leben haben und sich nicht
nur vom lustprinzip leiten lassen
die voraussetzung dafür ist ein gewisser
wille etwas zu erfinden
ein interessantes leben ist ein ich sage
nicht man könne nur in der politik
erfinderisch sein
man kann sich in der liebe erfinden man
kann künstler werden oder sich wissen
aneignen
es gibt verschiedenste bereiche in denen
man sich abfinden kann das wahre leben
so lautet der französische titel dieses
buches das wahre leben ist für mich ein
leben in dem man eine fähigkeit in sich
entdeckt die man sich nicht zugetraut
hätte das ist wahrhaft freude
ich nehme auf das beispiel die liebe
denn das ist das einfachste übung in der
nahrung die liebe zu einem menschen in
der ekstase des verliebtseins in der das
leben verwandelt erscheint entdeckt man
eine ressource um die man nicht wusste
um und man fühlt sich befähigt zu dingen
die man sich nie zugetraut hätte
in allen lebensbereichen schaffen doch
jene momente ein wahres lebenswertes
intensives leben in denen man diese
entdeckung macht die heutige politik
hingegen löst keine solchen folgenden
gefühle aus sie erweckt im gegenteil den
umgekehrten eindruck nämlich dass man
weit weniger erreichen kann als das wozu
man eigentlich fähig
das ist also mein leitsatz natürlich
braucht es dafür den willen den ich mein
vater gelehrt hat aber nicht nur man
muss zum beispiel auch begegnungen
lassen die einem etwas seltsam
erscheinen man muss sich auf unsichere
erfahrungen einlassen
man darf nicht für alles was man macht
eine volle risiko garantie erwartungen
zu rigoros exit man muss die tücken des
lebens akzeptieren das risiko warten
denn dadurch entdeckt man ungeahnte
fähigkeiten die sich komplett
kontrolliert und um damit anzufangen sie
haben sie selber schon mehrere male
gesagt empfehlen sie beispielsweise das
komplett verrückte zu tun nämlich sich
neu zu verlieben
das sagen sie in ihrem buch lob der
liebe das ist ein passagen verlag
erschienen ein verlag mit dem sie schon
ganz ganz lange zusammen arbeiten ganz
viele ihrer bücher erscheinen um diesen
verlag und der in diesem buch lob der
liebe sagen sie tun sie das verrückte
verlieben sie sich was genau ist denn
verrückt am sich verlieben
die liebe zeichnet sich dadurch aus dass
sie durch ein klares ereignis ausgelöst
wird die begegnung mit jemandem eine
begegnung die man den umständen des
lebens verdanken die kommunen der
politik auch wenn man es uns noch so
sehr glauben machen will die liebe ist
nicht kalkulierbar
es bringt nichts im internet die person
zu suchen die einen ähnlich ist und die
gleichen interessen hat über die man
sich unterhalten kann man muss die
begegnung viel mehr dem zufall
überlassen der zufalls charakter der
begegnung eröffnet neue möglichkeiten
waren da haben wir ein ähnliches schema
wie beim ereignis von dem ich gesprochen
habe
durch die begegnung werden die
möglichkeiten des lebens erneuere und
verwandte und es gibt einen moment wo
man das akzeptieren muss es passiert
nicht einfach von selbst
es besteht das risiko dass es einen
überwältigt dass man die welt anders
sieht und in seinem selbstbild
erschüttert wird
man wird aus der bahn geworfen
martina für es ist keine kleinigkeit zu
akzeptieren dass eine andere person in
ihrer ganzheit ins eigene leben eintritt
dass er an auch ein engel sein
doch wenn man deshalb die begegnung
vermieden würde man eine wichtige
erfahrung verpassen
eine erfahrung die das leben erweitert
verbessert und intensiviert
auf einer weise wie man es sich nie
hätte vorstellen können
und ich denke das ist der moment in dem
wir als teil der menschheit als männer
und frauen die wir diese erfahrung
machen können
die erfüllung unserer existenz erleben
die richtung des tores accompli frémaux
gibt es denn diese liebe heute überhaupt
noch viele leute suchen sich heute den
partner ja algorithmus im internet man
kriegt die perfekte person die perfekt
zu einem passt so gespielt mit einem
profil genau das habe ich ihnen ja
gesagt ich glaube und schreibe es
übrigens auch in meinem buch das die
liebe heutzutage bedroht ist aber ich
sage ihnen nicht nur die liebe sondern
auch die politik ist bedroht nach und
nach verkommt sie zur verwaltung der
wirtschaftlichen bedürfnisse sind die
polizei wird also reduziert auf die
wirtschaftlichen belange die liebe wird
reduziert auf die frage ob man sich gut
versteht und ob man schon im voraus
sicher sein kann dass es funktionieren
wird
doch etwas ähnliches beobachtet man auch
in der wissenschaften denn sie steht
immer mehr im dienst der technik und
muss sich der frage stellen wozu dient
sie man braucht sie um ein neues produkt
herzustellen um die kapitalistische
maschinerie am laufen zu halten und so
weiter auch die kunst ist in einer
schwierigen lage
denn sie ist heute sehr auf den markt
ausgerichtet und auf dem kunstmarkt weiß
man nicht genau ob es um den
wirtschaftlichen oder künstlerischen
wert gilt
wir leben also in einer zeit in der die
vier register der menschlichen
kreativität bedroht sind
warum weil ein wert alle anderen
überragt der geldwert der preis der
dinge auch der preis der arbeit wieder
lohnen usw
es ist eigentlich eine these die auch
eva illouz verträgt in ihrem in ihren
büchern über die liebe das sie sagt die
liebe ist heute bedroht weil sie eben
sozusagen unter der kapitalistischen
ägide ständig auf dieses
kosten-nutzen-verhältnis hin überprüft
wird
aber wenn ich ihnen voll und wir sagen
die liebe ist verrückt und zwar dann
wenn die reben aus dieser
vollkaskomentalität herauskommen und uns
einfach überraschen lassen über
fallenlassen von der liebe dann müssten
wir doch auch sagen wir müssen uns immer
wieder neu verlieben da nur wenn wir uns
immer wieder neu verlieben dann kommt
wieder ein ereignis zustand in dem wir
wieder neue sichtweisen hinzugewinnen
also das wäre dann ein plädoyer gegen
eine langfristige beziehung aber das
leben für mich sie sind eigentlich für
die lange beziehung und ich stehe
tatsächlich für die langfristige
beziehung ein
kommen wir zum philosophischen kern die
sachen zurück ob das ereignis in diesem
fall die begegnung mit einer anderen
person neue existenzielle möglichkeiten
schafft das heißt die möglichkeit ein
anderes leben zu führen zeigt sich durch
die arbeit die man in diese möglichkeit
investiert die erfahrungen die man damit
macht sind gut wenn man in der politik
nicht aufgeben sollte weil man
auseinandersetzungen hat darf man auch
in der liebe nicht weil die ersten
schwierigkeit aufgelegt im gegenteil die
lösung eines problems das in der
beziehung zum anderen auftaucht zeigt
sich wozu die kraft der liebe fähig ist
ich bin also nicht nur für langfristige
beziehungen
wenn zwei sich wirklich lieben fordere
ich sie vielmehr mit vehemenz auf
durchzuhalten in schwierigkeiten die wir
bei jedem prozess unvermeidbar sind
gut wäre auch ein mathematiker um ein
beispiel aus der wissenschaft zu nehmen
kann nächtelang über einem problem
brüten aber mathematiker sein heißt
nicht aufzugeben sondern hartnäckig die
lösung zu suchen jemanden wirklich zu
lieben ist das gleiche auch mathematiker
da spricht wirklich etwas aus ihnen
heraus was sie ja auch selber in ihrem
leben haben einerseits diese philosophie
und anderseits die mathematik die jetzt
irgendwie zusammenbringen in diesem bild
dessen was uns auch überraschend kam der
zufall aber auch das dranbleiben und ich
denke nebenbei bemerkt mein vater war
auch mathematiker er war sehr wichtig
für die mathematik kann als beispiel
dienen weil ein mathematisches problem
etwas eindeutiges ist man kennt das
problem hat alle seine komponenten und
kann es manchmal trotzdem nicht entweder
man gibt drauf oder man sucht wenn man
spaß hat an der mathematik hartnäckig
nach die lösung und ich garantiere ihnen
lieb wenn man sie gefunden hat ist die
freude erstaunlich ich vergleiche das
immer mit einer bergtour
der aufstieg ist mühsam der atem geht
schwer nach einer weg ehre kommt noch
eine sie kennen das doch wenn man oben
anlangt fühlt man eine herrliche
entspannung und genießt die aussicht
ähnlich ist es in der mathematik und
auch in der liebe hat man ein problem
wirklich gelöst spürt man eine große
freude
gehen wir zurück zur politik sie haben
an einer stelle auch gesagt im grunde
genommen ist die liebe der
kleinstmögliche kommunismus was haben
denn liebe und kommunismus miteinander
gemeinsam kam mit liebe irgendwie auch
politik machen will dann sollte man die
haare nicht vermischen
ich sage immer dass die vermischung die
registern und denen ich gesprochen habe
der ein bisschen gefährlich unseriös
die liebe in die politik einzuführen ist
etwas viel verlangt
die politik ist eine kollektive aktion
in der es geht ein gutes einvernehmen
eine übereinkunft zu finden
weiter muss man glaube ich nicht gehen
es ist nicht nötig sich zu leben
es genügt wenn man sich einigt auch das
was zu tun ist und über die ziele
diskutiert
in der politik geht es also um
einverständnis einigung und
übereinkommen hingegen greift viel
tiefer
da geht es den anderen voll und ganz zu
akzeptieren notierung es reicht nicht
sich über gewisse dinge zu einigen
eigentlich hat die internet liebes börse
das register verfehlt man gewinnt den
eindruck es gehe um politik wenn man in
gewissen punkten einig sei funktioniere
die beziehungen in der realität stolpert
man dann über etwas das man nicht
vorhergesehen hat
vielleicht ein stück warten problem er
muss sich überlegen wie diese
gemeinschaft zustande kommt haben jetzt
gesagt es kann sich nicht darum handeln
was man sich einfach liebt sondern es
reicht sich irgendwie zu verstehen sich
zu verständigen auf ein gemeinsames team
aber gemeinschaft die muss sich ja
irgendwie ergeben weil die kann man sich
einfach herstellen die kann man nicht
erzwingen
im übrigen auch ein problem über das
exelon hat sehr viel nachgedacht hat und
wenn sie an den kommunismus glauben dann
müssen sie sich gedanken darüber machen
wie gemeinschaft entstehen soll
die dann eben auch bereit ist
beispielsweise zu teilen und zu
verteilen gerechter miteinander
umzugehen
ich hätte wieder das ist ganz klar das
große probleme genug
wie man weiß stecken im kommunismus die
begriffe gemeinsam und gemeinschaft aber
ich denke in der kommunistischen politik
ist die gemeinschaft in erster linie
eine projektgemeinschaft
sie wird gebildet durch das gemeinsame
projekt die beziehungen der menschen
anders zu organisieren als durch die
vermögens- hierarchie durch die
beziehung zwischen den armen und den
reichen und durch die lohnarbeit
deshalb geht es um eine
projektgemeinschaft und nicht darum dass
man zusammenlebt und sich alle lieben so
funktioniert das politische wie shell
oder politik also dunkel sie im
kommunismus kommt zudem dass rittel vier
prinzipien die ich vorhin erläutert habe
zur anwendung nämlich der
internationalismus die ware
kommunistische politik ist
weltumspannend da geht es nicht nur um
ein einzelnes land
das ist einer der gründe warum der
kommunismus in russland und china
scheiterte
ihr blick unter anderem im nationalismus
stöckl kommunismus ist also eine
projektgemeinschaft die sich nach und
nach formt und stärker wird ihre
entwicklung zwischen dem projekt
kommunismus und dem kommunismus selbst
gibt es denn auch keinen wirklichen
unterschied durch das projekt wird
dessen gemeinschaft gebildet
denn das ist charakteristisch für die
politik und da gibt es ja auch aktuellen
wirklich ein problem dass unklar ist wie
wir damit umgehen dass sozusagen die
transnationalen unternehmen an der macht
die sie haben ein stück weit die
staatsmacht überragen und je nachdem
welcher richtung sie angehören es gibt
linke die sagen wir müssen von diesem
internationalismus runterkommen wir
müssen wieder mehr an das lokale denken
wir müssen wieder die lokalen
demokratien auch die nationalstaaten
stärken und es gibt die andere richtung
der sie angehören die sagen nein wir
brauchen eigentlich so etwas wie eine
neue internationale aber da stellt sich
die frage was haben denn die arbeit sind
denn jetzt zum beispiel in der schweiz
oder in frankreich wirklich gemeinsam
mit den arbeitenden in china die
arbeiter in der schweiz haben mit den
arbeiten in china die vorstellung meinen
die sie von der zukunft haben können
die politische situation wenn sie die
momentane situation nehmen ist sie für
jeden anders
was haben die 264 personen die gleich
viel besitzen wie die halbe
weltbevölkerung gemein mit den anderen
wirklich so wie die vier heutigen
unterschiede bezüglich der nationen
situationen und saläre sind
struktureller natur
daher ist es klar dass jede politik der
erneuerung daran arbeiten muss diese
unterschiede zu verringern
anstatt sich damit abzufinden als seien
sie wird verschiedenste probleme
schaffen
aber nehmen sie zum beispiel die
aufteilung der welt in nationen hier
gibt es zwei aspekte ein aspekt den man
nicht übergehen darf ist die
landessprache
wir müssen hier zum beispiel alles
mögliche machen und miteinander sprechen
zu können
das ist die linguistische aspekt dann
gibt es die herkunft das erbe die kultur
die religion das alles existiert das
streite ich nicht ab
was man aber sicher sagen kann aus
diesen unterschieden dürfen keine
ungleichheiten entstehen
und ich denke die große maxime dessen
was man kommunismus oder auch anders
nennen kann
sie hat mein name die maxime ist vor
allem zu zeigen dass gleichheit nicht
gleich identität die gleichheit kann
sehr gut in der verschiedenheit gelebt
werden ein wichtiger beweis dafür ist
die gleichberechtigung von männern und
frauen was heißt sicherlich dass frauen
und männer gleich sind es heißt dass es
weder ungleichheit noch hierarchie
aufgrund der geschlechter zugehörigkeit
geben darf in jeder frage geht es also
darum gleichheit durch die
verschiedenheit und nicht gegen
zu schaffen das ist sehr wichtig denn
die leute haben immer angst gleichheit
entstünde zu lasten der verschiedenheit
sie verhindere die verschiedenheit im
sinne einer gleichmacherei im gegenteil
ware gleichheit zeichnet sich durch
verschiedenheit aus sind alle
gleichmacht die maxime der gleichheit
keinen sinn wenn wir alle das wollen was
sie wollen herbert jung wie sieht ihre
welt aus wenn wir das erreicht haben was
sie eigentlich wollen was sie anstreben
opel-modelle module und restaurant ich
glaube die welt bleibt bunt gemischt und
sehr komplex die frauen mobil
es wird weiterhin verschiedene sprachen
und geschlechter geben
sykoras aber was allen gemeinsam sein
wird ist ein menschliches bewusstsein
der gleichheit
das ist der punkt
das heißt in der französischen
revolution ging es um die freiheit in
den kämpfen und im widerstand hat man
brüderlichkeit erlebt wenn auch als
kampf drunter stunde aber in der
gleichheit wurden keine große
fortschritte erzielt genau da müssen wir
weiter gas sei die vorrangige liebte das
schlusswort herbei
ich habe heute ein richtiges plädoyer
von ihnen gekriegt fast schon einen
vorsatz bündel fürs nächste jahr wie
sollen wirklich wollen und zwar ohne
vollkaskoversicherung und wieder alle
widerstände dranbleiben und wollen
vielen dank für dieses becker je danke
für dieses gespräch jetzt gleich geht es
weiter mit einem wahren ereignis und
zwar einen dass die kunstwelt
revolutionierte sehen sie das berührende
porträt der performance künstlerin
marina abramovic die die kunstszene mit
rücksichtslosen körpereinsatz aufmischt
ja und wir von der sternstunde
philosophie wir verabschieden uns jetzt
von ihnen für dieses jahr
ich danke ihnen sehr für ihre treue und
ich freue mich auf viele neue
sternstunden 2017 am 8 januar geht es
wieder los bei uns und zwar mit der
ersten sendung meines neuen kollegen
yves bost sie dürfen gespannt sein
bis dahin wünsche ich ihnen einen guten
ein sport- und frohe festtage
[Musik]